by popular demand let's talk about
dinosaur this is the one for whatever
reason everybody has been pleading for
me to do even though it technically
isn't a 2d animated film my guess was
that the film must be so good that
obviously everybody wants me to review
it um okay I didn't quite see it as that
but uh alright let's start on the
beginning and I mean really from the
beginning let's go to the trailer
because this is the first thing a lot of
people saw the trailer was just the
first five minutes of the movie with a
little dinosaur egg being picked up and
traveling across fields of real life
landscape and computer-generated
dinosaurs and I gotta admit it was
pretty cool it got a lot of us really
hyped up but then when a lot of people
saw the movie their reaction was kind of
similar yeah what is he wha they talk
damn it I thought they were really gonna
do something new with like the animals
that don't talk so I like in Fantasia or
do this really adult story but okay oh
well you know what maybe you'll be like
Land Before Time you know where it's
this really big story and really
touching characters and just this
timeless but you need is a little help
from love monkey love monkey huh come on
hot stuff
let's get going okay which celebrity is
at the Hat girls I'm known as the
professor of love professor really
they have professors in the dinosaur age
yeah I know I'm probably over reading it
but for God's sakes look at this opening
look at how real they try to make these
dinosaurs they're obviously trying to
tell this really really big story and
I'm sorry you can't do it with these
voices and these references if it was
something like out of a ruler Kipling
novel maybe but love monkey oh stop
saying that the story you've heard it a
million times
it's Moses again a young one is driven
from his family to be raised by somebody
else
years later he grows up but find
something threatens his kind in this
case a meteorite so he finally comes
across his people and wouldn't you know
it he emerges a leader again I'm willing
to put up with this if they give us
something new but these characters are
so bland and so tired the minute you see
the main character you know what he's
gonna be
he's gonna be naive but determined a
wisecracker but knows when to be serious
the all-around good role model who
cracks a few jokes every now and then
what about the supporting characters
yeah the female love interest who is
just there to be the female love
interest yeah they talk twice and all
the Sun they're like laying eggs at the
end when did that happen the jerky
leader is the jerky leader oh wait
actually we have to jerky leader so that
way we can do both story arts the one
with a guy who realizes his mistakes and
the one with a stubborn jerk who never
catches on well great you gave us two
cliches for one you got that weird thing
I never get where some of the dinosaurs
talk but some don't you could argue
maybe they're not as intelligent but
look one of them's like a dog I'm sorry
that's really weird if it was like a
different animal maybe but when all the
rest of the dinosaurs can talk this is
really kind of odd it's like talking to
a person and then another person is
suddenly licking it scratching at you
it's I don't know just odd even all that
beautiful landscape we were promised in
the trailer most of its just traded in
for bland boring looking desert and I
know what they're getting across they're
supposed to be suffering the meteor hit
it's supposed to be bad times but when
your story and your characters are as
bland as this the least you could do is
give us something interesting to look at
now to the movies credit despite the
fact that the story's been done a
million times and these characters
haven't done a million times it's not
bad I mean there's a few things I like
for example I really like these two
older dinosaurs they're constantly
bringing up the rear they know they're
slowing people down but at the same time
they're trying their best to be
optimistic and hopeful the supportive
mother though again done a million times
it's actually a genuinely likeable
character too and I do sort of like it
when the one leader realizes his mistake
and is even ready to die for it before a
story like this where obviously they're
trying to tell a great big tale with
great big characters nothing much really
stands out about it something like Land
Before Time really works because not
only is it done with Dinosaurs but it's
done with the young dinosaur and they
don't use terms like the love monkey
they use terms that are a little bit
more timeless and you feel the pain and
the struggle they have to get through
because they're much younger that makes
the danger so much more graver and they
all have unique personalities and you
could easily gravitate towards them you
could get angry at them or you could get
sad for them you could get happy for
them why is it I always praise this move
whenever I'm talking about Disney films
so yeah I hear the film didn't do
phenomenally well at the box office you
can probably see why but again a lot of
people really want me to do this so I
guess a lot of people out there probably
really enjoy it if you do that's awesome
okay I said I don't think there's
anything ethically wrong or really
insulting about it it just seems like a
really been done story as well as really
been done characters and I know that
there's about five original stories that
we're all doing variations on in like
ten original characters that we're only
doing variations on but the more they
can hide it or at least bring something
new to the table that's what makes a
difference and for me I just didn't feel
this broad enough and hated I just
couldn't get into it but hey apparently
a lot of people did and I'm sure a lot
of people still do if you're interested
to see what some people are talking
about give it a watch but if the same
things that annoy me also annoy you I
probably say give it us